today on the Matt Walsh show as the
economy teeters on the brink of collapse
and many Americans are already finding
that they have to choose between paying
their mortgage this month and feeding
their kids some government officials are
hinting that the shutdowns could go on
for weeks or months longer others like
President Trump are suggesting that we
should get the economy going again soon
I think Trump is on the right path here
and I'd like to talk about what opening
up the economy again could look like and
what steps we might take in order to
protect the vulnerable as we get back to
our lives which we need to start doing
and soon also five headlines including
Madonna's very insightful a video that
she shot from her bathtub a lot of
people are making fun of it but but I
thought she was it's quite poetic and
she offered some great insights into the
coronavirus we turn to people like
Madonna in times like this that's why
I'm so happy that all these famous
people are making all these videos
because I wouldn't know what to think or
what to do without the famous people
telling me and in our daily cancelation
I cancel yet another media outlet for
maybe the most egregious fear-mongering
headline we have yet seen throughout
this entire ordeal all of that on the
way but first a word from Tacomas you
know nothing nothing makes you feel more
American I say then wearing cowboy boots
at least that's been my experience I
never I admit was one of my one of my
flaws one of my few flaws as a man up
and up until when I discovered to Kovas
is that I had never worn cowboy boots
and now I wear them all the time
including I put a picture up online a
few weeks ago of early on in the
quarantine I was wearing my sweat pants
with cowboy boots because in my opinion
you know they go with any pants at all
and that's just my opinion don't quota
koba's does not necessarily endorse
sweat pants and Kalla bites but I do
Tacomas cowboy boots are hand made with
high quality full grain leather by
world-class boot makers they're built to
be comfortable right out of the box and
for every occasion you know at home in
the office out on the town with tons of
timeless styles to koba's are designed
to be as fashionable 50 years from now
as they are today and that's it's a
great thing about having a timeless
style so you don't have to update it you
know if you're if you're try
to keep up to date with the footwear the
kids are wearing these days then you
have to buy new shoes every three and a
half days or whatever it is but cowboy
boots are always fashionable always
great and they cut out the middleman
sell direct to you at an honest price
that's truly amazing for this level of
quality plus shipping returns and
exchanges are free and easy so do what I
did get yourself a pair of two Kovas
cowboy boots today at tacomas dot-com
slash walsh that's tec ova s.com / walsh
t'k OVAs dot-com / walsh by the way
before we get going into the topic at
hand here I have a question for any
parents out there tell me tell me if
you're experiencing this - maybe I just
want to make myself feel better but
maybe we're just extra lazy my wife and
I but we have basically given up on
making sure that our kids get dressed
into normal clothes
throughout this quarantine they haven't
left they haven't left our house except
to walk around you know outside for a
week now or more so my daughter at this
point has worn nothing but pajamas since
last Wednesday and both of my sons look
like they got drunk and raided a party
city so here's what my younger son was
dressed in yesterday let me just show
you this we've got the t-rex rain boots
superhero pajama pants leather jacket
and like a Native American buckskin
shirt and a plastic spoon that he says
it's his lightsaber actually his
lightsaber
it is dark Vader's lightsaber according
to my son and he can't be convinced
otherwise by the way that's how it's
pronounced that's all it is I think he
pulls it off though this is why I get
jealous of young kids that they can wear
stuff like that I wish I could dress
like that if I could dress like that and
get what I would get away with it my
wife would allow it I would dress like
that every day but he pulls it off now I
did just you know of course I did tell
him that wearing that shirt is cultural
appropriation and I said cultural
appropriation is violence to which he
responded oh okay
and then ran away humming the Darth
Vader theme to himself so this is a kid
who just as not frankly is not very woke
anyway president Donald Trump is now
signaling that he wants to end
these lock downs and at the conclusion
of our 15 day quarantine period which is
up on Friday I believe we still don't
know exactly what his plan would be or
if he'll still feel this way on Friday
so we don't know exactly it's it's still
somewhat vague but last night he tweeted
we cannot let the Cure be worse than the
problem itself at the end of the 15-day
period we will make a decision as to
which way we want to go okay the problem
of course is that Trump doesn't have the
power to tell individual governors and
other states to end their lockdowns so
we could be headed to one hell of a
showdown between Trump and state
authorities across the country who knows
how that's going to shake out meanwhile
as expected this this tweet from Trump
has provoked lots of panicky overblown
responses as literally every single
tweet of his does this especially though
and people are talking about how Trump
is gonna kill your grandparents and and
so on and so forth the governor of New
York on the other hand has implied that
his state may remain locked down for
months he hasn't said that exactly no
official has said that exactly but but
as this has gone on you have you have
more and more of them with the exception
of Trump who seemed to be indicating
that yeah 15 days probably not that
could be three weeks four weeks four
months who knows they they at least are
indicating that the potential of a
month-long lockdown of millions of
people is a possibility that they're
weighing it's an option that they're
considering now the Cuomo of the
governor of New York also justified over
the weekend these draconian measures by
saying even if it saves one life it will
be worth it this is reminiscent of what
the mayor of Los Angeles said last week
and we talked about where he was asked
directly what what about the economic
impact what all about all the people who
are gonna be out of a job isn't this
isn't this too much is it and he's isn't
isn't it not worth the cost he said
every life is precious oh that's all I
could say every life is precious on the
and we'll get back to that in just a
second those those responses on the
economic side as yahoo finance reports
real estate billionaire tom barrack said
the US commercial mortgage market is on
the brink of collapse and predicted a
domino effect of catastrophic economic
consequences and the Federal Reserve
Bank of st. Louis President James
Bullard predicted this weekend that very
soon the unemployment rate could hit 30
percent 30 percent so put that in
context the worst unemployment rate in
American history as far as I'm aware was
25 percent and that was during the Great
Depression 25 percent that's the worst
ever he's talking about worst than the
worst ever unemployment rate the worst
unemployment rate in my lifetime and
probably in your lifetime too depending
on how old you are was about 10 percent
now the unemployment rate rarely hits
double figures
double digits and what it does already
people are starting to freak out this
would be three times worse than the
worst we've ever seen and that's where
we stand right now we've got some
government officials hinting that these
shutdowns could go on for a long time
we've got others we'll mainly just jump
into indicating that they're coming to
an end and we've got the economy on the
brink of collapse of catastrophe
collapse you know whatever words you
want to use and that's not that's not
being dramatic or panicked
that's the collapse of the commercial
mortgage market is a catastrophe 30%
unemployment is a catastrophe
and those two indicators are just the
beginning they barely scratch the
surface
think about this the need of the state
of New York the city of New York I
should say is is the economic hub or one
of the major at least economic hubs of
the United States if just in New York
were to shut down on its own if it were
just New York shutting down for weeks at
a time
that would send shockwaves that alone
could be catastrophic the restaurant
industry employs about 13 million
Americans if just the restaurant
industry were to shut down the domino
effect of that could be catastrophic for
the whole economy
you think about you know companies like
think about professional sports all of
the money that they pump in the economy
if just they were to shut down again you
would have potentially catastrophic
Domino effects well all of this is
happening at the same time that and much
more now I've said that I'm on board
with Trump's 15 day 15 days to slow the
spread that's what we originally told I
think we can survive 15 days I'm not
sure what exactly it will prove to have
accomplished with respect to the virus
and that's where I've been saying all
along I have no choice but to leave that
to the scientists I don't know what 15
days of a lockdown what is that really
gonna do hopefully it'll do something
maybe if I had to guess maybe it gives
our hospital and met hospitals and
medical community and scientists a
chance to to catch up basically
scientists were working on treatments
and and and and working on a vaccine
gives them a little bit of time to catch
up maybe that's what this is doing and
maybe that's a significant thing worth
the cost but when I say worth the cost
it's an it's important to note that the
cost has already already been
substantial for a lot of people over the
weekend I asked people to send me their
stories I solicited this on Twitter
asking people who've lost a job or lost
income over the last week or two because
of these shutdowns to you know either
send write a comments or send me a
message telling me their situation what
their story is
and I got hundreds of messages I read
many of them they're they're pretty
harrowing and keep in mind it's been
only a week for most people now I
originally planned to share some of
these stories on on the show but so many
of them include so many personal details
about people's situation in their
financial situation not that they're
giving me their bank account information
or something I just mean you know their
personal details about their jobs and
everything that part of the story so I
don't feel comfortable sharing that even
if they gave me permission so I'm not
going to do that suffice it to say from
what I'm reading
lots of people are already nearly in a
financially dire state small business
small business owners especially can't
just drop to zero revenue even for a
week without there being significant
consequences potentially fatal
consequences to their business we can't
that's not how business works it's not
how the economy works you can't put it
on pause cryogenically freeze it or
maybe stuff it in your freezer like like
a pack of ground beef and then thought
back a you know thought again and return
to normal like nothing happened
the economy doesn't work that way
business doesn't work that way and many
working families are paycheck to
paycheck if someone's working paycheck
to paycheck living paycheck to paycheck
and you take one paycheck away it's
gonna have a cascading effect in their
lives and that could be nearly ruinous
so it seems like if this is over after
one week after one more week most people
many people will narrowly avoid the
financial break narrowly and not
everybody I got one message from a woman
just one example woman's single mother
left an abusive relationship recently
got a job recently was was starting to
you know starting to get into the into
the swing of things at her job loses her
job because it's in the restaurant
industry when they were when that shuts
down now she's at a shelter with no
income her three kids and and no job
lots of stories like that
that's after one week so what does it
look like if things continue for a month
two months well it looks like a disaster
I mean it looks like thousands of
businesses going under millions of
people out of a job unable to pay their
rent or their mortgage unable to feed
their kids destitution desperation on a
massive scale this again is not not some
sort of dramatic doomsday prophecy how
do you avoid that if the government
prevents people from working for weeks
and weeks at a time what's gonna happen
people need money to live now we'll have
more to say about this in just a moment
and I want to get into the
justifications that were being given by
government officials which to me have
been very disturbing especially in the
last few days the things that are being
said they've been disturbing to me I
want to talk about that just a second
but first a word from LifeLock you know
right now especially a lot of hackers
are bored tight on money stuck at home
on their computers and and that's that's
that's not good for you especially if
you're sending your private information
using the computer especially as we head
into tax season now thank God
tax season has been extended a little
bit longer so we have now until July
15th but still we're in that a lot of
people are you know trying to take care
of the taxes doing other things online
you've got these hackers there and your
name your social security information
lots of valuable info about yourself is
is being emailed around and that means
that there are hackers there who can
take it
pluck it and then and then sell it on
the dark web or use it to commit
identity theft so many other
possibilities to help prevent this
that's why you need LifeLock the number
one most recognized brand and identity
identity theft protection
LifeLock monitors for uses of your
personal info alerts you to possible
suspicious activity and if you become a
victim of identity theft a dedicated
identity theft restoration specialist
will work to fix it for you so no one
can prevent all identity theft all the
time but having life lock means one less
thing that you have to worry about and
that's a huge help right now because
nobody needs more things to worry about
I think it's the one thing we don't need
is more things to worry about so join
now and save up to 25% off your first
year just go to LifeLock comm slash
Walsh That's Life LA comm slash Walsh
for 25% off all right Governor Cuomo
says Governor Cuomo says all of this is
worth it if it saves one life that's
obviously insane that logic is insane
it's the logic of a madman if he really
believes that
he's a madman I don't think he really
does in fact given that he's given that
the abortion clinics are still open
because apparently they are essential
being able to kill your baby during this
time is essential that makes me even
more sure that Governor Cuomo doesn't
mean it if you want to save just one
life shut down the shut down the
abortion clinics and nothing else and
you've saved millions of lives not just
one but as I said it disturbs me greatly
that the people making these calls are
saying things like this they are giving
a science and data in numbers they
aren't they aren't showing us that
they've weighed the consequences of
economic collapse against the
consequences of an uncontrolled outbreak
they aren't showing that if they've done
it they aren't telling us if they've run
these calculations and taken seriously
the effects of an economic collapse
we're not we're getting very little
indication of that from the people in
power especially from these governors
who are shutting everything down instead
they're giving us platitudes ambiguities
that's not good enough
you can't plunge our country into a
great depression and ruin the lives of
millions of people with this as your
stated reason if it saves one life it'll
be worth it now as I said last week I'm
not sure exactly what the balance is at
what point does the potential number of
lives saved actually justify a potential
Great Depression and millions of
destitute people I don't know I damn
sure know though it isn't one one person
isn't going to do it and because I don't
know where that line is exactly or when
exactly it is crossed I have to think of
it this way let's weigh the worst-case
scenarios the absolute worst-case
scenarios on both sides because we're
hearing a lot of the worst case scenario
on the health side on the disease side
of it we're getting a lot of that we all
know what the worst case scenario is
because we've been told millions of
times now
worst case scenario there is we get the
economy going people get back to their
lives the disease picks up with a
vengeance millions of mostly elderly and
sick people die
hospitals are overwhelmed and many more
died because of that on the other side
though and this is the part that that
many of these government officials
aren't talking about on the other side
we shut everything down for many weeks
tens of millions of people lose their
jobs wide swaths of the population
plunged into destitution parents unable
to feed their children many died from
lack of shelter lack of food many more
died from suicide as they watched their
lives unravel before them and American
society as we know it is finished
worst case I'm not saying either of
those worst cases will happen but they
are the worst cases and anybody who
advocates for one solution over the
other it has not grappled with the worst
case outcome of their solutions should
be ignored in my opinion now it's been
it's been troubling that that so many
people advocating for indefinite
lockdowns are not even acknowledging the
possibility of a Great Depression
potentially worse than the first Great
Depression and are therefore not
grappling with what such a thing would
mean and what the human cost would be
much of what we get from folks on that
side if you start talking about this
they'll say it's really stupid things
like all you care about is your 401 K
and your your paycheck and your your
your poor five gotten this a lot o you
care about is your portfolio you think
working families that are living
paycheck to paycheck trying to figure
out how to feed their kids you think
they're worried about their portfolio
you think they have a portfolio no they
need to feed their kids they need money
to do it a real simple equation here you
know so on my end
I've thought about this the courage and
I've come through that I think it's
better to risk the former worst case
than the latter better to risk the
disease killing lots of people which is
a horrible thing again we're dealing
with worse cases here but better to risk
that than to intentionally destroy our
economy and the lives of millions of
people in order to maybe prevent the
disease from doing that I'm not aware of
any country ever intentionally plunging
itself into a depression in order to
avoid a virus or to avoid anything as
far as I'm aware no country has ever
tried that method before to solve any
problem I think probably we shouldn't be
the first now you've probably heard this
by now but when weighing these matters I
keep thinking about a lot of people have
thought about this quote because I've
seen it all over the place and I think
it's worth if you haven't heard it I
think it's worth reading a CS Lewis
quote from an essay about living in the
Atomic Age as he did so this isn't
obviously about a viral pandemic and
it's not exactly analogous but there is
a some comparisons here that can be made
so here's what he in one of his essays
here's what he says he says in one way
we think a great deal too much of the
atomic bomb how are we to live in an
atomic age I am tempted to reply why as
you would have lived in the sixteenth
century when the plague visited London
almost every year and as you would have
lived in a Viking Age when Raiders from
Scandinavia might land and cut your
throat any night or indeed as you are
already living in an age of cancer and
age of syphilis and age of paralysis and
age of air raids and age of railway
accidents an age of motor accidents in
other words do not let us begin by
exaggerating the novelty of our
situation believe me dear sir or madam
you and all whom you love were already
sentenced to death before the atomic
bomb was invented and quite a high
percentage of us were going to die in
unpleasant ways we had indeed one very
great advantage over our ancestors and
aesthetics but we have that still it is
perfectly ridiculous to go about
whimpering and drawing long long faces
because the scientists have added
one more chance of painful and premature
death to a world which already bristled
with such chances and in which death
itself was not a chance at all but a
certainty this is the first point to be
made and the first action to be taken is
to pull ourselves together if we are all
going to be destroyed by an atomic bomb
let that bomb when it comes find us
doing sensible and human things
praying working teaching reading
listening to music bathing the children
playing tennis chatting to our friends
over a pint in a game of darts not
huddled together like frightened sheep
and thinking about bombs they may break
our bodies a microbe can do that but
they need not dominate our minds now
that doesn't mean that I think we should
fling open the doors and charge back
into our normal daily lives while
ignoring the coronavirus and just
accepting that people are gonna die
obviously that's not what we should do
obviously no matter what you do you have
to avoid you have to try to avoid the
worst outcome right now the government
is trying to avoid economic ruin by
keeping things locked down and sending
us checks we haven't sent any checks yet
they're still debating it
I think they should send the checks but
I don't think that plan is sustainable
so rather than keeping everything locked
down indefinitely while taking specific
steps to hopefully avoid economic
ruination why not open things up again
and take specific steps to hopefully
avoid mass casualties from an outbreak
when I take it from that direction I
have an idea of what that might look
like and we'll talk about that just a
second but first if you haven't had a
chance to see some of our new content
called all-access live you should head
over to Daley wire comm check it out
Jeremy boring and ben shapiro kicked it
off last week then we did all we all did
live streams each day over at daly wire
comm and will continue all of this week
as well at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
all access live is a lot more relaxed
than our normal programming it isn't
really a show it's less focused on
bringing you news and information it's
more about sitting down and having a
conversation with with you at the end of
a long day we've been getting a lot of
amazing messages from our daily wire
community during these trying times
and we can see that they're trying that
they're coming
a positive and heartfelt place so I I
think that these these live streams are
great not just for our viewers but also
for for us as well I really enjoyed
personally kind of therapeutic to sit
down and have a conversation that goes
many different ways isn't necessarily
focused all the time on on this thing
that we've been talking about now
incessantly for weeks this show is
intended for our all access members but
during this national emergency and time
of isolation we've opened it up to all
of our members and in doing so
accelerated the launch so please let us
know what you think of it and if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight join us on all access
live over at daily wire comm I'll be
doing one I believe on Wednesday again
so I'll talk to you then on Wednesday
now how about this for a night rather
than keeping everything locked down
indefinitely while taking specific steps
to hopefully avoid economic ruination
why not again open things up we take
specific steps though while we're doing
that to avoid mass casualties from an
outbreak just a brainstorm here tell me
what tell me what the problem would be
with something like this did a potential
plan we could think about number one
open the economy up let young and
healthy people work feed themselves and
their families to quarantine the nursing
homes keep them quarantined 3 tell other
especially at-risk people to remain home
for now for tests aggressively and if
somebody has the virus quarantine them
aggressively now it seems to me that
this plant has a better chance of
avoiding devastation from the disease
than a shutdown with stimulus checks has
of avoiding a depression and maybe
that's the way we should be thinking
about this right now there are no
perfect answers there may not even be
any good answers but there are answers
that can better account for the
potential worst-case scenario on the
other side and here's a good thing
if we do this and we get people back to
work then we don't need to keep sending
people checks I think that people should
get at least the one stimulus check for
the to compensate them for what they've
lost in the last week or two but we
don't need to keep doing it and if
everyone's back at work then we could be
more targeted and we could start
thinking about the the at risk let's say
so there's someone who's even younger
and has severe asthma and says it's I
can't risk it I can't go out right now
has to stay home okay well or you might
have this a you know an older person an
elderly person even who doesn't have a
retirement savings can't live off of
Social Security alone and so depends on
their job at Kroger they can't go back
to work either there's gonna be lots of
people in that in that boat a lot fewer
though than there are right now where
everybody's at home so in this scenario
we could be more targeted and focused on
supporting those people finding relief
for them specifically it'd be a lot
easier to do a lot cheaper to do and we
could be a lot more specific with it I
certainly don't think that we should go
back to work and tell people who can't
work still to stay home and say well
you're on your own figure it out no no
we should take care of them it'd be a
lot easier to do though if we're not
plunging everybody else in the
destitution as well I have heard one
other quick thing the objection I've
heard from people of well what about
those who have elderly people in the
home let's say you're living with an
elderly parent you go off to work you
come home you pass it off to them what
about that well listen maybe an analogy
here as I mentioned on the show probably
frequently as I was whining about it I
had the flu a few months ago and it was
the flu it wasn't the Krone of ours
tested positive for the flu pretty
severe case of it and now the flu yes is
not the same as the corona virus but the
flu is more deadly is in fact much as
far as we know is much deadlier to kids
especially babies than is the corona
virus and so you know when I had the flu
we have a newborn at home so it's a big
problem I've got a severe case of the
flu got a newborn
plus three other young kids if they get
it especially if the baby gets it that
could be potentially fatal and so what
did i do i quarantined myself up here in
this room it's like the upper area of
our of our house i quarantined myself
and I didn't come out for days and it
was tough it was especially tough on my
wife but it was what we had to do so my
point is if if parents are already doing
that with respect to the flu when it
comes to their babies and their young
kids considering the flu is again
deadlier to to children than the current
of viruses
parents that are already doing that have
been doing that for years these are the
kind of measures you have to take to
make sure babies and other and your kids
don't get the flu well then why can't a
similar thing be done with elderly
people and the corona virus just you
know already parents even if they don't
have the flu most parents if they're
responsible exercise great caution
during flu season especially with their
kids when it comes to germs and
everything else and it's a lot harder to
do with kids because you can't convince
them to walk you can't convince a
two-year-old to wash his hands or to
keep his hands out of his mouth you just
can't do it with older people you can
tell them wash your hands they'll put
your hands in your mouth pretty easy to
at least avoid you avoid doing that so
why couldn't we take a step like that if
you have an elderly person in a home why
can't you do something similar as to
what I did to protect my baby when I had
the flu yeah I mean you know I know it's
not easy you know there aren't any easy
answers here but there are potentially
answers that don't involve destroying
the entire economy and plunging millions
of people into poverty now let's move on
to headlines five headlines number one
CNN Headline says California's beaches
hiking trails and parks were packed with
people over the weekend despite a state
order to shelter in place and avoid
close contact with others now this kind
of thing people still going to beaches
and parks has provoked in keeping with
the theme lots of anger and panicky
responses from people saying that these
folks on the beach are going to get all
of our grandparents killed etc and I'll
probably get myself into trouble here
with this but I have to say and I have
to just be honest I really don't see the
problem with going to a beach I haven't
this whole
I don't really understand why people are
freaking out about about about folks
going to the beach or going to a park
I'm not saying to go run out to the
beach on my word don't listen to me I've
already told you that but I'm just
telling you what my feelings are right I
don't see the issue I mean look at this
photo that CNN has provided with their
article you look at this I don't know if
I assume this is a photo from what the
beach look like this weekend
it's there it's their photo ok well it's
hard to tell in the background but at
least in the foreground you see you see
there are little clumps of people
presumably families and they're pretty
nicely spaced there appears to be
several feet in between all of them so
let me ask you what are the chances that
somebody contracts the virus on the
beach in the heat in the Sun when
they're sitting on the sand 10 feet or
20 feet away from the nearest other
person even if that other person has the
virus and even if they coffin even if
they direct their coffee bright in your
direction and these are all big IFS
what are the chances even then that you
would contract it 10 feet away outside
on the beach in the Sun I'm not saying
it's non-existent I'm not saying it's
impossible I just what are the chances
is it nearly large enough statistically
to justify even mild concern and if you
aren't going to get the virus from
somebody coughing several feet away
outside then where will you get it on
the sand in the sea water I'm not saying
I'm not saying it's impossible I'm just
saying it's here's another way of
thinking about it if I were to call the
Health Department and say that I was on
the beach and somebody with the virus
coughed five yards away would they would
they give me a test would they or would
they be more likely to laugh me off the
phone so I don't know I I mean I I've
taken my kids to the park several times
I admit I confess I've taken my kids the
park we've been outside walking there's
not anybody within several feet of us I
really don't see the issue
I just don't number two multiple reports
last night say that Harvey Weinstein has
had or Weinstein has tested positive for
the corona virus in prison which means
in the span of about
we Harvey Weinstein got sentence of 23
years in prison believe it was 23 and
also then contracted coronavirus not a
great week I have to say of all the
weeks a person can have that's probably
not gonna be in the top 10 in terms of
favorability ratings but I've seen
people online claiming that this is
Karma for Harvey Weinstein all I have to
say is to Karma
listen if you orchestrated a whole
pandemic just to get Weinstein then
might I suggest next time consider being
a little bit more surgical in your
approach to these matters just a
suggestion far be it for me number 3
during the lock downs a group of leftist
anti Trump people have been pulling a
Robin Hood act or at least what they
think is a Robin Hood act by stealing
from grocery stores and giving the
stolen goods to the homeless they took a
video of themselves doing this so check
this out
[Music]
you
how false and cheap the concern for the
poor is among these people did you see
the floors and countertops in that house
the house of the thief I mean they look
like faux wood and faux granite but
still that's not a poor person's home
that's an upper middle class home the
kind of home where you can afford to pay
extra for floors and countertops that
look more expensive than they are so I'm
sure my point is that these people could
go out and afford to buy some lunches
and supplies for the homeless instead
they'd stay steal it they'd steal it
from a local local grocery store we're
paying customers working families will
now be deprived of those supplies that
they need and can't buy because they
were stolen this is not charity this is
not generous anybody can do that anyone
can go steal it's also demeaning and
dehumanizing to the homeless people
you're you're enlisting unsuspecting
homeless people as accomplices in your
endeavors you're giving them stolen
goods without telling them that's what
it is do you think the homeless man
eating that food knew that it was just
down the pants of a thief who stole it
from the grocery store so I'll throw
these people in jail and throw away the
kids that's my feeling of that number
for the New York Health Department has
released a guide to having sex in the
age of the coronavirus because this is
what we need the government for of
course to dispense this kind of advice
and I I oh I thought I would read some
of this to you but I really can't
actually because it is so graphic in the
sexual advice they're giving but to
summarize what they're saying is because
of the corona virus you probably don't
want to have sex with strangers you
probably want to have sex with you know
people who are in a close circle to you
and you probably want to just exercise
precaution so it seems what they're
saying is that that having sex with
random strangers actually isn't healthy
or safe turns out that you should like I
don't know maybe even be devoted to or
committed to maybe even love the person
you have sex with
you might even want to consider being
what's it called what's that they
married yeah maybe that's it zhenia then
you really don't have to worry about it
if you're married to your spouse and
you're both warrantied no concern number
five Madonna made some waves pun
intended
you'll get it when you see the video and
then you'll laugh hysterically at my pun
it made some waves yesterday with a
coronavirus related video that she
posted a lot of people are making fun of
it I think it's insightful poetic
philosophical inspiring check it out
that's the thing about Kovac 19:00 it
doesn't care about how rich you are how
famous you are how fun you are how smart
you are where you live how old you are
well the amazing stories you can tell
[Music]
it's the great equalizer and what's
terrible about it is what's great about
it it's terrible about it is it's made
us all equal in many ways and what's
wonderful about it is that it's made us
all equal in many ways like I used to
say that the end of human nature every
night we're all in the same boat and
this [ __ ] goes down we're all going down
together yes yes Jarvis please fetch a
camera and a harpist I'm in the tub
covered in rose petals and I have some
have some insights I'd like to share
with the common folk yes please
well listen I get why she's concerned
first of all the disease does especially
affect the elderly so it makes sense
that you know she would be taking it
personally but you see how desperate
these celebrities are for attention
they're stuck in their homes without
paparazzi without cameras in their face
all the time and it's driving them crazy
and these are the same people who
usually say they don't like all the
attention they don't like the paparazzi
well you put them in a home for a week
without it and look what happens there
they're desperate anything they can do
so this is maybe one of the best reasons
for stopping the quarantine because what
are these people gonna be doing in a
month a month from now I swear we forget
about them we are three days away from
Miley Cyrus performing ritualistic
cannibalism on Facebook live just for
attention we are three days away from it
you heard it here first
now we'll get to my to the daily
cancellation before we wrap things up
for the day today we'll be canceling MSN
for the following headline take a look
at this drug touted by Trump to possibly
treat virus can kill in just two grams
now some background on this Trump has
been talking about a drug called the
chloroquine I think it's a it's
pronounced which could maybe potentially
treat the China virus and the media has
been very angry at Trump for mentioning
this positive news they don't like to
mentioning positive news in fact CNN
which could also be
but I guess there's always an
opportunity to cancel them so I let this
one slide they accused Trump of quote
peddling unsubstantiated hope which
really takes cynicism to a new level I'm
a cynic and even I've never used that
phrase before unsubstantiated hope
that's not even cynical that's like
something Spock would say or something a
barely sentient robot your hope is
unsubstantiated your hope has a 3.2
percent probability rating
unsubstantiated hope we rate your hope
unsubstantiated so MSN comes with this
angle though they say two grams could
kill you two grams that sounds scary
doesn't it sounds scary until you
realize that literally any substance you
put into your body could be broken down
and then categorized as potentially
deadly so I'll give you some examples
all of these headlines are technically
true but obviously misleading tylenol
touted by many to treat headaches can
kill in just 0.3 ounces
caffeine found in products sold by
Starbucks and coca-cola can kill in just
two teaspoons a vitamin a found in
popular vegetables like carrots can
cause dizziness nausea and death if
taken in the wrong dose think drinking
water is a good idea 14 people have died
from consuming too much of it and so on
now I don't know anything about this
drug that Trump is talking about but I
do know that any substance can kill you
if taken in the wrong dosage and when it
comes particularly to medicines it
doesn't take much of it which is why
there's a lot of chemistry involved and
figuring out the correct dosage but if
you don't understand the chemistry then
it's it's pretty easy to be terrified
and I don't understand the chemistry so
I it's easy to terrify me with this
stuff so sometimes I mean even I'll fall
for it when I hear these headlines of uh
or someone says oh did you know that
that's a so many different kinds of
fruit have arsenic in them arsenic
gasped
yes well arsenic occurs naturally in
soil and does end up in very small
amounts in your apples and your oranges
that only sounds scary because we don't
know chemistry and because we watch a
lot of
by movies where arsenic is used as a
poison to kill the bad guys now it is it
is that it can be a poison but it's also
a chemical element found in lots found
in lots of stuff and it takes lots of it
to poison you just like h2o can well in
fact water can easily kill you if even a
little bit goes in your lungs doesn't
take much water in your lungs to kill
you and even if it goes in the right
place even if it goes down the right
tube and you drink it even then if you
drink too much it could kill you now
granted you'd have to drink a whole hell
of a lot of it to suffer water
intoxication but that is a real thing
people have died from it and maybe one
day maybe if I'm in the mood I'll tell
you if you want a good laugh I'll tell
you the story of the time that many
years ago when I thought that I had
water intoxication because I just read
about it for the first time and realized
that I've been doing a lot of running
that in the past weekend had been
drinking a lot of water and I convinced
myself that I had water intoxication and
I went to the doctor to ask about it and
the doctor laughed in my face literally
laughter have you ever have you ever
been laughed in your face by a doctor
it's never happened to you you want to
talk about dehumanizing there are a few
things more embarrassing than that they
have your doctor laughing at you
but yes he did laugh and explained to me
that now you'd have to drink I don't
know what it is exactly but you'd have
to it's happened to some people but
you'd have to drink a lot a lot a lot
anyway that's not the point today I'm
not the I'm not the cancelled one all
right
MSN is for their absurd fear-mongering
headline and so that's the end of Emison
I just cancelled them all right and I
suppose we will leave it there and hope
everyone is hanging in there through
these shutdowns hopefully we'll
hopefully there's some light at the end
of the tunnel be safe out there
god bless and Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]